we wouldn't dare play the music but
Howard Jones song plays over 80s title
card cliche
what is it flower one has a picture some
kind of line the last one is on the chef
considering the theme zoomed in on these
hats twice in the past minute I'm
getting a strong criminais ssin that
this will happen entirely too much
during this show parenting get this but
how would you know which cake to get him
work that he even wanted cake she just
walked up and this was well after Sean
mentioned the fudge cake also fudge cake
something that the man on TV is a thief
because he rings his hands nervously is
utter nonsense what if he had anxiety
over talking to reporters or he had to
pee really really bad and was just
trying to get to the bathroom hi I'm
Shawn Spencer this hole walks up to the
counter and talks to the person on the
phone rather than waiting like a normal
person is the stuff of movies and TV
shows nobody does this in real life and
if you know someone who does this I
think you may need to choose better
people to be around
don't you try and trivialize police work
I think you're doing a bang-up job of
that all by yourself and I get that
being annoying as part of Sean's charm
but I'm with him here yeah him being
able to solve all of these crimes by
watching news reports is odd but it
would be a lot easier to prove he wasn't
involved in these crimes so this seems
like a waste of everyone's time
including mine because this pilot was
over an hour long got the information
because I'm psychic close enough roll
commercials Nick know what's amazing is
it that the two arresting officers who
showed up are the two Shawn got visual
cues from earlier to be able to pull off
these psychic shenanigans and Shawn also
got lucky that Lassiter tipped his hand
to doing the horizontal tango with not
Juliet go to detention room number two
all the evidence is in his left shoe
Shawn was never privy to which room mr.
blood-thirsty was taken to and I guess
that means he is psychic I can't be lazy
writing his alibi checks wait I'm
getting something the clock says
ten-four
earlier when Sean arrived it said 1052
this show jumps to so many conclusions
I'll be damned if I let it get away with
jumping through time - case closed but
you are about to ask him to assist you
on a high-profile kidnapping case
so this antagonistic approach does seem
a bit odd just pointing out that the
lead character of this show at one point
in his history opened an acupuncture
clinic and jab people with needles just
because he could yes everything you need
is right in front of you you just have
to pay attention which is apparently not
a skill any of the cops currently at the
scene have there none of those guys
there and not one of them is looking out
the window to see this obvious dumpster
dive the CD case is totally nice
why would someone throw this out this
was a dated reference even in 2006
what are you Lamaze breathing it helps
I'll cover a few birthing centers just
let me know when the contractions are
two minutes apart this pilot might be a
little rough around the edges but the
one thing it nails from the get-go is
the great rapport between James Roday
and Dule Hill
she reads Vonnegut oh yes I don't know
how in the early aughts reading Vonnegut
was the identifier of a cultured person
because those of us who were reading
Grisham king or Patterson when our just
[ __ ] well Shawn Spencer if you need
to ask any questions just one do you
currently have a boyfriend I'm with you
on the eye roll do lay this show can
clearly be funny but this Katerina
obsession bit comes off as a hundred
percent creepy Shawn is the guy I'm
supposed to be rooting for I think since
you've been here all you've done is dig
through the trash you know the victim's
sister and post-acute old boyfriend
that's also known as the douche bag
slacker holy trinity fine
solve this case by myself wouldn't Shaun
be doing that anyway as much as I love
Kashan as a team I'm not sure I
completely understand what Gus is
bringing to the table I mean other than
a car and his ability to write stuff
down how did you get in far less
effective on a second floor landing
agreed but why did Shaun bring the key
inside instead of just leaving it where
it was did he know he would get the
perfect timing cue for a visual joke
wait there's more speaking of more there
are entirely too many limes in that bowl
Oh should I slice this up for the road
pineapples welcome also pineapples are
not a snack fruit for the road and even
if someone wanted to be adventurous and
eat juicy fruit while driving there is
no way it can be sliced up quickly this
whole snack suggestion is a pineapple of
lies why no Gus that makes too much
sense
we need incompetent police so Shawn can
accidentally himself into solving cases
of the chicken enchilada extra chicken
or maybe she doesn't want chicken maybe
she feels like secretly sleeping with
one is enough chicken in her life let
everyone think I'm working my way up the
ladder the hard way okay get it the hard
way also this is a terrible way to
introduce a strong female lead and I
hope they find a way to fix this
narrative with thoughtfulness instead of
just sending a mixed message that the
affair is somehow just her fault by
shipping off the female lead to another
department and letting the male lead
just stay in his position no you see the
plan hinges on quite literally the
direction of the wind
Billy cams working the grill so so Billy
camp has the worst hay fever I've ever
seen a couple of things one how did
Shawn see that Billy was working the
grill when Shawn calls out to Lassiter
he has not looked in a direction to see
who's working in the kitchen his eyes
have been focused on Lassiter and
Lucinda the whole time
second a couple of things have to work
in Shawn's favor Billy has to be
sneezing while holding up the chicken
and Lassiter has to be looking in that
direction to see it none of this should
work but hey we have an hour to fill so
why not they're not even a hundred
percent sure the kidnap victim is there
yet they've just seen a dog would you
really be putting out a call to SWAT
before that was checked out is SWAT even
needed
you couldn't just use five or six armed
cops and have you considered that Camden
McCallum may have been alive the first
time we went to that cabin
have and in all future episodes when I
see Sean commended for all the cases he
solved I will always think yeah but
remember that time he might have let
that guy get murdered to get positive
word out on his new detective agency
you're in over your head mystic psychic
shaming what are you gonna do when you
get caught you definitely will if you
keep discussing it this loudly in public
places go by the bag Sean holders Gus
around lies to him manipulates him and I
just can't figure out the special
friendship glue that holds them together
maybe it becomes more evident future
episodes but as for now I'm saying Gus
should go back to Big Pharma so somebody
at that house did pay ransom hmm so much
of this show is dependent on ridiculous
coincidences basically Shawn super
powers are being observant counting hats
lying and jumping to conclusions like a
lemming leaps from a cliff unfortunately
gut feelings but whether or not a glove
fits is you're not even a cop yep so why
invite him into your home in the first
place you're right I'm a psychic and I
saw the whole thing
cinema why are Shawn and Gus being led
out from the house they were in Gus's
car when the cops showed up I'm not sure
how good of an actor James Roday is but
he is 100% committed to this role in
this kind of exuberance delights me to
no end this is a rich man with probably
a team of lawyers there is zero chance
he gives up the goods because of Shawn
shouting ouch and so the fake psychic
finds his place in the world a
fraudulent terrible friend with an
unhealthy grasp on how to relate to
women for all of these reasons I don't
want to watch the show again but I will
just to find out if that damn tile is
replaced actually it's our agency I put
your name on the lease as well bad
forgery to the list of ways that Shawn
shows he cares why is Shawn driving
Gus's car man cannot be trusted
[Music]
my name is Johnny wish wishbone Johnny
wishbone and I'm a psychic from that in
the st. croix if you've ever wanted to
know what it's like to probe into the
backend of cinemasins and learn our
deepest darkest secrets buying the sins
podcast is just what you need each week
writer is Aaron that's me today and
Jonathan yep discuss what it takes to
create the content that you enjoy on
YouTube hopefully enjoy they probably do
I mean even if they don't when you talk
about it that's true I guess I'll just
wrap this up real quick and let you know
that you can listen to behind the scenes
here on YouTube or search for the show
on your favorite podcast player yep
Alan I won't deny you I'm a nymphomaniac
okay I mean this is a huge
misunderstanding I was really going out
to pee I'm walking in the bushes I trip
over this guy and all some there all
these cops in there are conscious and
it's okay
we believe you doctor doctor doctor
daddy threatened to cut him off
permanently this was about 18 months ago
18 months but wait there's more and this
conversation is okay my name is Andrew
Campbell I'm a teacher at Roosevelt High
School there's another teacher here who
wants to have a fistfight with me after
school so I need help